hey guys in this mkbhd video we're going
to be taking a closer look at the beat
phoenix survivor mid tower chassis now
you're looking at the case right here
like i said it's a small case a mid
tower and it can fit micro atx and
standard atx size motherboards this is
something that you're going to be using
a lot if you like to go portable but an
ultra a really powerful laptop computer
just doesn't do it for you this is
something you're going to be using if
you go back and forth between lan
parties if you're a really active mobile
gamer and you know there's going to be a
monitor wherever you end up and you can
really build your computer in this case
and take it wherever you need to go
the case itself is all black and in the
front you're going to find these grilles
where your fans would be i know it's a
little bit difficult to see with the
lighting and the color but at the top
you have your hard drive bays your five
and a quarter inch bays where your
optical drive and things like that will
go and at the front you have a glowing
bitfenix logo and depending on the model
you get this will glow either red or
blue the case itself has a very suede
matte feel it's actually one of those
things where you think it's very durable
you can bump this thing around knock it
into things not that you'd want to but
this case is going to be able to stand
up to that and it does feel really nice
to the touch
in this covered section here you'll find
power reset and fan leds two usb 3.0
ports to usb 2.0 ports esata and audio
in and out and that's very easily
covered to prevent dust from getting in
there when you're traveling and speaking
of travel accommodations up top on the
top of the case above the 200 millimeter
fan is a travel handle it's not
something you're going to see too often
on your larger full tower cases or even
the half x that i'm using later
for uh extended atx motherboards but
something as small as this for like a
micro atx build this can really be
useful for when you're traveling often
and it hides away nicely
now all of you land gamers out there
know that when you buy a case that you
plan on going portable with well you
want it to look good and i definitely
think this case satisfies that need it's
got nice rounded curved edges it's
really nice ultra portable well i
wouldn't say ultra portable but nice and
thin case those top and bottom curved
parts actually have to come off to
reveal the inside of the case so you'll
need your phillips head screwdriver to
take the top part off the bottom part
off and the side panel off that's one of
the cons that i found with this case
around the back of the case you have
your power supply spot you have your
seven pci expansion slots on the left
hand side you have the place for your
motherboard i o shield and on the right
hand side you have mounting spots for
either 120 millimeter fan or 140
millimeter and you also have two either
cable routing or water cooling grommets
i wouldn't really suggest using water
cooling when you're going portable so
these can be used to route the cables
from the front of the case to the back
where your motherboard i o ports are so
overall the back of the case looks
pretty good no real complaints here
other than the fact that those are those
the spots where those phillips head
screwdrivers will have to come out for
you to take the back uh the back of the
case off and get the side panel off so
if you ever want to do any major
upgrades you're really going to have to
sit down with this case and unscrew a
couple of things and perform your
upgrades and screw it all back together
overall i would have absolutely no
problem recommending the bitfenix
survivor to anyone who is a mobile gamer
or just values a good sized small case
that's sturdy and very durable to be
honest i'm not using the phoenix
survivor for my computer build an
upcoming how to build a computer series
but i definitely have this on my
secondary pc wish list if i was building
something like a media center pc or
something that i didn't want to take up
a lot of space this is a classy looking
case and i definitely recommend it for
those of you who are interested anyway
this has been the bitfenix survivor and
thanks for watching this mkbhd review
video peace